[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANOJ GUNTI: Welcome to today's
webcast on harnessing the power
of API data.
My name is Manoj Gunti, and I'm
the product marketing manager
for Apigee API Management
Platform at Google.
Also joining us today is
Adam Brancato, from Citrix,
a company that has been a
longtime customer of Apigee.
And I will let Adam introduce
himself in his own words.
ADAM BRANCATO: Hey, everyone.
My name is Adam Brancato.
I am the senior manager
of customer apps
over here at Citrix.
Basically our team is
responsible for a section
of our web apps that deal with
customer contacts, profiles,
single sign-on,
authentication, authorization,
everything around individuals
and their companies.
MANOJ GUNTI: Thanks, Adam
for joining us today.
So before we begin
the webcast, I
wanted to quickly cover
a few housekeeping items.
What you see on
your slide should
resemble your webinar console.
On the bottom left,
there's a Q&A console
where you can post your
questions at any time
during this webinar.
Once again, a quick reminder.
You don't have to wait
until the end of the webcast
to post your questions.
Feel free to post them at
any time during this webinar.
And next to the
Q&A console, you'll
also see a Resources console.
We will be making references
to a lot of resources
during this webcast.
And all the links in the
download or list of pages
should be available in
the Resources console
next to the Q&A console.
So we will begin this webcast
by talking a little bit
about the evolution
of API programs,
how they have transformed
from being agents of access
to actually being agents
of digital transformation.
We will see how the app
evolution has impacted
or created more pressures
on certain stakeholders
within the organization, and
how API data can actually
be leveraged to address
some of those pain
points of these stakeholders.
And then I will
pass it on to Adam.
And he will walk us through
the API journey of Citrix.
He will talk a little bit
about some of the use cases
that they are trying
to solve with API.
He will also talk a little bit
about why they chose Apigee
and how has been their
experience working with us.
And then we come to the
most interesting topic
of this webinar, where
Adam will actually
be demoing the real time
dashboards and the instances
of Citrix.
And then when we come back,
we will talk a little bit
about what are the different
ways in which API data can
be leveraged within
an organization,
and what other
problems can be solved.
So I thought to explain,
or to talk a little bit
about the evolution
of API, instead
of me going through some slides,
the best way to showcase that
is to actually show you a quick
video of one of our customers,
AccuWeather, who also has
been partnering with Apigee
for a very long time.
So let's take a look at what
AccuWeather is doing with API.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I became fascinated
with the weather
when I was three years old
when I fell in love with snow.
And by the time I
was seven, I knew
I wanted to be a
weather forecaster.
So AccuWeather I
started in college
as a second year
graduate student.
And AccuWeather is
now the largest source
of weather forecasts and
warnings in the world.
We've achieved this by
having the greatest accuracy.
- So AccuWeather was
founded 56 years ago,
really on pen and paper,
serving business customers.
Over the last 10
to 15 years, it's
really morphed into
a digital solution.
And APIs basically power
that entire transformation.
- The API is a way of feeding
the best weather information
into other apps and
integrating easily however they
want to use it.
- We've been using Apigee
for our API developer
portal for over 18 months.
And since day one,
when we literally
started with zero
developers, we've
now branched out to
over 50,000 developers
out there in the community.
A lot of people don't realize
how many products and services
are out there in the marketplace
using AccuWeather APIs to power
that backend.
We serve nearly 50 billion
API requests per day.
- Apigee made it very simple
for us to set up self-signup
for potential clients.
It gives us the ability
to monetize our API,
and also to offer free APIs to
people so they can try it out.
- By having access
to analytics, we're
able to really get real
time information for what
our developers are
doing, what they like,
what they don't like.
It allows us to make that
quick judgment to what we want
to do moving forward
in the future,
as well as helping
our developers
get better experiences
out of our APIs.
- The weather forecast is more
important than it's ever been.
The weather can cause a
flight to be canceled,
rain out a baseball game.
It interacts with everything.
There are millions of
developers and potential users
around the world for this API.
They can take our
data and our forecast,
integrate it into
whatever they're doing,
and make it better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MANOJ GUNTI: So this is
very interesting, isn't it?
So in the whole video, you
have not seen anywhere mentions
about access, about
integration, and all the stuff.
So what we are talking today
is about creating experiences
for customers, creating
digital transactions,
and actually enabling digital
transformation through APIs.
And we are not seeing
this trend just
with AccuWeather or some
of the other customers.
But in everyday,
day-to-day conversations
that we are having
with our customers,
we are seeing that
the topics of API
management have evolved beyond
just access and integration.
Like enterprises today are
exposing their core business
assets.
And if you take the
example of AccuWeather,
their core business asset
is the weather data.
And they are exposing them
to a fleet of developers,
and also several businesses that
are actually using this weather
data through APIs,
and building them
into their business
applications, as well
as consumer applications.
And AccuWeather it is actually
monetizing those APIs.
So it has essentially triggered
a new business channel
for the enterprise, leading
to unlocking newer markets, as
well as additional revenue
streams for the organization.
So that is how APIs have
evolved over the last few years.
And when you think of
APIs actually transforming
businesses, what we also
see is several customers
are-- several prospective
customers are actually
still thinking of APIs
as just a gateway.
But when you are doing
business critical stuff,
I think it is very,
very important
to start thinking of APIs as
not just one-off projects,
but to actually think of them
as business applications, right?
Because you're not
just providing access
within your business
systems internally,
but you are now actually
reaching out to your customers
through APIs.
And these products, when you
are treating them as a business
application, need to
have a full lifecycle
management to be incorporated,
but not just a simple gateway.
Because the fact that a simple
gateway cannot give you all
the security levels.
It cannot give you all the
monitoring capabilities.
And most importantly,
it will not
give you the
capability to make it
easily consumable for a
wide range of developers.
So what does a full lifecycle
API management platform entail?
So it starts all the
way from the ability
to create a proxy, design, test,
all the way until publishing.
And making sure
that it is secure,
making sure that the right
people have the right access
to the right APIs.
And also, at the
same time, to do
a lot of analytics
in the backend
to analyze, potentially, how are
developers consuming the APIs?
And are the APIs
available, up and running?
And how do I protect them
against abuse from [? bot ?]
and the internal and
external [INAUDIBLE]??
So what the evolution of APIs
and treating APIs as a product
means is that now it is not
just an API developer who is
involved in the whole program.
So a wide range of
stakeholders now
get involved into this
whole program, all the way
from a product or a program
manager to a security or IT Ops
person, to the line of business.
If I were the product or program
manager of a large API program,
then I am very much interested
in understanding which
APIs are my developers using?
What are the most
popular API [INAUDIBLE]??
How do I increase the
overall developer engagement?
And for sure, I
will have to report
the success of my program
to my senior management.
And how do I very quickly
and easily do that?
And from an IT operations
and security perspective,
what happens is if your
mission critical or business
critical applications
are powered through API.
Let's take an example
of a recent scenario
where your promotions,
or your payments,
or your product catalog
availability [? reveals ?]
everything is powered
by a different API.
And imagine you are in a
Black Friday and Cyber Monday
situation.
And even a slight
performance delay of an API
could lead to significant
loss in your revenue.
How do I, as an
operations person,
make sure that my APIs are
always available, they are
always performing as expected?
And at the same time,
if something goes wrong,
how do I quickly diagnose
the root cause of this API
and bring it back to
life as soon as possible?
And from a security and
[INAUDIBLE] perspective,
how do I make sure that
all the developers that
are building these
amazing APIs adhere
to the security policies
of my organization,
as well as my industry?
And of course, you will
not be able to scale up
any of your API programs without
the buy-in and investment
from the line of business.
And if I were the VP of IT,
the CIO, CTO, or even the CFO,
some of my biggest
concerns would
be, what is the ROI
of the API program
that I have invested in?
How do I measure it?
Where shall I invest more, and
which API should I actually--
which API programs
should I actually retire?
And what is the business
impact or the consumer impact
of this whole investment
that I'm making?
Am I able to reach
out to newer markets?
Can I unlock new
revenue streams?
Or what else can I do with this?
So what is happening
on the other side
is as you build and
scale your API programs,
you actually start to
touch each and every person
in the API lifecycle.
What we call an API
lifecycle is all
the way from the backend
system that you're exposing,
to the API teams that
are building the APIs,
and the developer that is
using those APIs to build
amazing apps, and the consumer
who is actually using the app,
and indirectly using the
APIs that are behind it.
So across all these touchpoints,
as you build and scale
the programs, there's
a lot of data that has
been collected on the platform.
And this is one of the
other big advantages
that you get when compared
to an API gateway.
An API management
platform is essentially
able to collect all this
data and able to provide you
with the right insights
that will address
some of the problems that we
discussed in the earlier slide.
So Apigee API
Management Platform
is a full lifecycle
API management platform
that has several layers,
including the runtime layer,
the mediation engine, the
API analytics space, and also
the developer ecosystem.
So if we look at the
API analytics space,
Apigee today provides several
out of the box inbuilt
reports that help all
the different personas
that we talked about.
It provides you developer
engagement metrics
and the API program metrics
for the API product manager
or program manager persona.
And it provides
business metrics,
such as the revenue report,
the customer churn, et cetera,
for the line of business.
And it provides you
operational metrics,
like the availability, the
performance, the ability
to quickly diagnose
issues, linking your alerts
to the right
playbook so that you
can take the appropriate
remedial actions.
And also, security reporting,
which is about adherence
to compliance policies, and also
analyzing the runtime traffic.
And at the same time, looking
at the activity of the users
within your organization,
whether they're accessing
sensitive data or not.
So across all the
three personas,
we do provide metrics
and dashboards
that address some of the needs.
And what I will do now
is I will hand it over
to Adam who will talk a
little bit about Citrix, what
is their API journey, and how
is Citrix actually leveraging
all the data and the concepts
that we talked about,
and some of the use
cases or problems
that they're trying
to solve internally
by leveraging this data.
Over to you, Adam.
ADAM BRANCATO: So thanks, Manoj.
So I'll start off,
I'll just give you guys
a little bit of
background on Citrix.
For anyone that's
not familiar with us,
we're all about unifying apps
and data and secure workspaces.
We deal a lot with
virtualization of desktops.
We have NetScalers
that do load balancing.
We have Cloud platforms where
you can run your entire desktop
systems.
Things like XenMobile that
manage your mobile devices.
Basically, we
believe work anywhere
on any device at any time.
So that's a little
bit about Citrix.
Obviously, head to
citrix.com if you're
interested in more information
about the kind of stuff
that we do here at Citrix.
So going to give you guys a bit
of a background on the Citrix
API journey.
We've been working with Apigee
just about five years now.
It started with a simple POC
that me and some other team
members did.
We were evaluating
various API platforms.
And now it's been five years.
We have 40 production
APIs right now.
On the right-hand
side, you could
see some of the highlights
of the things we do.
We have SSO APIs.
We have ones that people use
to open support cases, asset
management, contact, all these
various things you see here.
One cool one to point
out that you'll see,
there's a Salesforce
spot listed right there.
One of the really cool things
we've done with Salesforce
is Salesforce themselves
have a lot of APIs,
as well as old legacy services.
Some are REST services,
some are SOAP services
that you can connect to
as a Salesforce customer.
However, depending
on their service,
it depends on the
authentication.
There's a bit of back and
forth and things like that.
So we actually wrote inside
of Apigee custom code
through Apigee's workflows to
handle that authentication.
And then we sat
Apigee on top of that,
so the consumers
really only have
to worry about an
API key we send them.
We handle the connections
with Salesforce.
So that was really
cool that we're
able to do all that in Apigee.
Don't have to update Salesforce.
And consumers don't
have to deal with that,
if behind the scenes,
our APIs are connecting.
Then internal and
external consumers,
we have, obviously,
external consumers.
But a lot of our traffic comes
from our own internal Citrix
teams.
We're all over the world in
several different departments.
And we expose APIs
to each other.
It's a great platform to do it.
Finally, it's simple.
Talk about some of those things,
but it's a real easy platform
to get started on, for
developers and the consumers.
So I'm not going to go
through all of these,
but here's a lot of the reasons
why Citrix chose Apigee.
One of the biggest one's is easy
user and consumer management.
It's really easy
to add new users,
give people keys,
take them away.
And I don't have to do
anything on my backend.
It's really awesome.
Multiple formats are supported.
Like Citrix, we've been
around for 30 years now.
So we have some
really new services,
and then we have some legacy
ones that aren't highly used,
that are in SOAP and
things like that.
It's really easy to put a
REST front end on top of it
and push it out through Apigee.
And then there's some
other ones in here,
tracking usage, which I'm going
to show you guys in a bit.
Reporting, monitoring.
It uses like a workflow UI to
do a lot of the configurations
and setup, which is really
cool and easy to do.
And then caching.
I'll actually show you guys
something with caching after.
If anyone is not familiar with
the caching feature of Apigee,
it's actually really
cool, because if you
have an API call that
is repeated often,
if you turn caching on,
the call doesn't even
go to your backend.
It just sends back
the same response.
Like if you have a
call that gets states
for a country, that doesn't
have to go to your backend
every time.
So you can cache that
on the front end,
and your backend
doesn't get hit.
If you're using
platforms like Azure,
Google Cloud to host your
APIs, that could definitely
help reduce cost.
All right, so now let's talk
about harnessing the power
of API data at Citrix.
So there's a couple
different ways
that we at Citrix,
and especially myself,
utilize a lot of the
different pieces of data
that are exposed from Apigee.
So the first one I'm
going to talk about
is the API Monitoring
dashboard, which has been around
for approximately, I
would say, it's relatively
new in the last year.
Manoj, did you want to talk a
bit about that platform real
quick, the API monitoring?
MANOJ GUNTI: Sure, Adam.
So API monitoring is
potentially a feature
that will address the ops
persona of an enterprise
business.
So what API monitoring
essentially provides
is near real-time metrics
that could help an operations
person actually look
at the availability
of the APIs, business critical
APIs, that will give you
an option to group some
of the most important API
as a collection.
And you can very closely
monitor the availability
and the performance metrics
of those collections.
And at the same time, it has
a very, very comprehensive
allotting capability, and very
flexible allotting capability,
I must say.
You can have alerts triggered
with various dimensions
and various performance
metrics incorporated.
And you can receive it--
there is options for web codes.
You can get it on your
PagerDuty, email, Slack,
and multiple channels.
And when you get an alert
through API monitoring,
your diagnosis process
becomes very, very simple.
When you click on a button--
and Adam will actually walk
you through these steps
in the demo.
But when you actually
click on the button,
you will quickly be able
to identify the root
cause of the issue
within one or two clicks,
without even going to any
other login tools, like Splunk.
This is very, very important
for a lot of customers of ours,
because it significantly reduces
the mean time to diagnosis,
and also the mean
time to resolution.
One, primarily because
the monitoring platform,
being totally
integrated with Apigee,
it gets a complete view
of the API value chain
that we discussed.
So across all these, you will
be able to very quickly, very
precisely pinpoint where
the issue has happened.
Is it because my
backend is failing?
Is it because the deployment
is not done properly?
Or is it because of the
front end application
that this proxy is
actually failing.
So we'll go to a
live demo of it,
but essentially, you
don't have to toggle
between multiple screens.
You don't have to do
the print sessions.
You don't have to look into
the logs and other screens
to actually diagnose the
root cause of the problem.
ADAM BRANCATO: Cool, thanks.
So what you guys see here,
I highlighted a lot of stuff
that Manoj just mentioned
about like ad hoc monitoring
of proxies, traffic,
errors, latency,
timelines for environments,
regions, custom alerts.
And I'll show you guys
that in a few minutes.
At the bottom here,
you see there's
a little screenshot I have.
It shows you what's
hot, what's broken?
And in a few minutes,
I'll actually show you
what that looks like live.
The next item we use
here a lot is something
I call real time dashboard.
So built into Apigee,
like this is built in,
all these dashboards
and little monitors
I'm going to show you
guys later to show you
current traffic,
latency, errors, payload.
It's very similar to the
API monitoring dashboard
that kind of focuses in on,
OK, here's what the problem is.
Now, the real time
dashboards give you
some more in-depth
stuff where you
can target specific things,
such as target performance.
So target performance
is how your backend code
is performing, what overall
performance might look at,
including going through
the Apigee layer
and your backend,
cache, any custom code.
So this really allows
you to dive deep
into things in real time again.
And I'll show you guys that,
and all the different things
that come.
There's a lot there to it.
And I'll even show you
an example of something
we did a few weeks ago, where
this came in really handy
to show us a problem
we were seeing.
Finally, the custom reporting.
So you can use custom
reporting to do
a lot of different things.
So some of the things like
track customer usage, traffic,
drill down into
specifics, performance
over long periods of time.
On the right-hand side,
some of these items
I listed, like quarter over
quarter comparisons, target
retirement, targeting
new quarterly goals
and new features.
I'll kind of explain
those a bit more.
OK, so here's all
these cool numbers.
And I'm sure a lot of people at
work at their various companies
all the time, everyone's like,
I want to see reports on this.
I want to see reports on that.
Show me what this--
show me these numbers.
One thing we try to stress
here at Citrix is like, OK,
we have these numbers
and these fancy reports.
Let's have action items.
Make them actionable.
It's great to show
numbers, but then there
should be action items
associated with them,
or else you just
showed a pretty chart.
So I'll show you some
of the stuff we've done,
and I'll show you some
real actual live reports.
So here's my guy
light himself on fire.
Let's do some demos.
I'm going to share my screen.
Hopefully, everybody
can see my screen.
All right.
If at any point
something goes out,
or while I'm talking if the
screen share's a little behind,
let me know and I'll try to
slow it down and coordinate it.
All right, so what you
guys are seeing right now
is this is our Apigee--
this is our dev
instance, which we
use for our non-production API.
So I'm going to show
you around there.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about
is that API monitoring item.
So while that's
loading, basically, this
is the dashboard I
was talking about,
where immediately, anytime--
so right now, you'll
see this for us, this is looking
at our pre prod environment
within our Apigee instance.
You can set up
different environments.
So pre prod is one of
our testing environments.
So if we get reports
or somebody else
wants to check on
the health of things,
and preventative
measures, because we
do have logging and things like
that, like Splunk, like Manoj
talked about, this kind of
gives us, OK, what issues
are we seeing right now?
So like up here in
the top left, you
can see, all right, how much
traffic we're getting a second.
Again, there's not necessarily
a ton going on right now.
It's testing, so
that's going to vary.
But then we could see, oh wow,
the account service for dev,
well the account API in
the US East, that's bad.
There's 91% error rate, or
something along those lines.
So someone would
investigate these.
Obviously, a lot
of these numbers
are high because this
is a test environment.
So people are testing
things all the time.
But I purposely chose
this environment
because it's real easy to see,
if there are things broken,
you can see this.
And then there's some latency
about, all right, wow.
That's taking 55 milliseconds.
Somebody might want
to look into that.
So these are all good tools.
If you want to see all of them,
I can click View all here,
and it would show,
what's the error rate
for all these different APIs?
And what's cool is it
gives you this hot spot
item you can click on.
If something's like
bad, or something
like that, it shows
me, bam, it'll
show me current trends for that.
Great, they're really up.
There haven't been any
errors over the last hour.
And you could play
around with these.
We could change the
environment you could see here.
So this gives you a real time
thing that you can fiddle with.
There's this timeline feature
which is very similar.
So this is if you want
to go look at hot spots,
so this tells me some hot
spots here of the errors.
This is currently for all the
proxies, the different regions.
But if you want, you can
target specific regions.
So for us, we have US West
Coast and US East Coast
right now for Apigee.
Those are where our
two regions are set up.
So you can filter by that.
You could filter by proxies.
You could see, we have a lot
of different proxies here.
So you could filter
down on like one
was the account service we saw.
So you can see, wow, look, cool.
There were 15,000 errors.
So clearly, something is wrong
with that service in the test
environment.
This is a great
way to drill down.
So if you do
investigate, it's going
to bring up another screen,
which is really cool.
So what this tells me is
here's all the different errors
that these proxies
are receiving.
So if I go to the
account, for example,
this is something
we're immediately, OK,
so this right here is getting
a message of adapter flow error
inside of the proxy.
So maybe something's
configured wrong.
But it's telling us
exactly what's going on.
We can filter this by
the different fault codes
and policies, et cetera.
So this is, again, another tool.
won't go into too
much more detail
here, but it shows a little
bit of the different items.
There's a lot more
I want to show you.
So one of my favorite
things is this alert.
So there's not a ton
of alerts turned on
in this specific environment,
because again, it's
a test environment.
And it would trigger more
often than you would probably
want to see.
But what's really cool is
to create a custom alert,
all you have to do
is hit that button.
You choose your environment.
Then you can choose what
you want to monitor.
We could say latency.
And if I could say, OK, if
the latency is greater than--
we could say, like 1,500
milliseconds for five minutes,
then we would want
it to send an alert.
And you can add a whole
lot more dimensions,
a whole lot more condition data.
But just do that real
quick for you to show you.
And then I could just put
in here my email address,
and then say how often do I
want to be bothered, basically.
So it would be 15 minutes.
You can do 30 minutes,
an hour, et cetera.
And then I would--
of course I forgot.
Then you could set it
up for a specific proxy.
Forgot to do that.
I don't care what region.
Do it for all regions.
Now I hit Save.
And of course, we have
to give it a name--
Account Latency Alert.
And you could set up-- there's
so many dimensions and factors,
like there's no time to
go through all of them.
But just to show
you a quick example.
When one of those gets
triggered, like here's one
I got earlier today.
I purposely set
some low thresholds
and broke stuff so you
guys could see that.
OK, cool.
This is the email it
sent me at 12:15 today.
Hey, here's the org,
here's the violations.
You click View Details.
If I actually
click this link, it
will take me right into this
API monitoring dashboard
and show me exactly
what rules I broke,
show me the latency over
this time period, et cetera.
It's all under this
Investigate tab.
And again, you can configure
those so many ways.
You can get alerts
through email,
and there's other methods,
as Manoj told you about.
So that's kind of a super quick
overview of API monitoring.
There's definitely more
to drill down into there.
But we'd be here for hours.
I will show you something
I mentioned earlier.
I called out with these
live dashboards, as I call,
real time.
So another one that we use is--
especially this one we actually
use in dev and production--
is post deployment.
Because as soon as we deploy
new versions of things,
we can monitor things
for errors, right?
So let's say we just
deployed this account proxy.
This shows me here's all the
arrows over the last day.
Again, something is
wrong, obviously,
because look at
all these errors.
You can see the
response times here.
So this is telling
me over the last day,
the average response time's
been 135 milliseconds.
And then down here's
the traffic per hour.
So I will show you real time for
a real item that we ran into.
So I'm going to change
to a different service.
what we call the
[? FTF. ?] This is
one of our single
sign-on APIs that we use.
I'm going to show you
a specific timeframe.
So we were working on
a new feature release
and we deployed a new
version of this API
into our test environment.
So soon as that happened,
we got a few alerts.
And actually, people
reached out to us too, hey,
we're seeing some latency.
And this is perfect.
You can see, so oh my god,
let me see what's going on.
And I went in and
I looked at this.
And you could tell exactly
when we deployed this, right?
Because the average latency
here was like 200 milliseconds.
And then all of a
sudden, about 10
o'clock Eastern time,
whoa, there's a big spike.
And now we're looking at
2,000, 3,000 milliseconds,
and some spiked over 5,000.
So we were immediately
able to see, OK,
that deployment today
definitely caused an issue.
Again, this is a
test environment,
but it's good because
we run unit integration
tests and some performance
things like that.
But OK, now in the
actual environment,
there's an issue
we need to look at.
This was really easy to see.
And if I send that out
over a 10-day period--
oops, let me go back here--
we fix this problem.
And there was a
couple iterations,
and we found out the
root cause of it.
But you can definitely see once
this loads what our items were.
This may take a
little bit of time.
So you can see
here, OK, this was
when we deployed the new one.
We reverted back.
We tried again, and et cetera.
And then you'll see
after a few days,
it's going to flatten out.
But that's the kind of stuff
you can see immediately.
Like oh, wow.
There's a new deployment.
Look at the spike
in response time,
or look at the spike in errors,
or something along those lines.
Finally, I'll just
show you or tell you
about there's this
target performance one.
I won't too much
into depth, as we're
trying to show you a lot here.
But anyway, basically,
what you can do here
is this is all your
backend that are hit.
And you could filter for
this based on IP addresses
and things like
that to determine
if you have latency for
specific backend IP addresses,
for example.
How much traffic is going
to different targets,
response times based
on these targets.
Again, errors, payload
size, et cetera.
So this is if you want
to specifically target
what your backend is receiving.
So the last one I'm going to
show you is Custom Reports.
So custom reports are basically
outside of all those traffic.
The other one that I
will mention-- sorry--
error code analysis.
I didn't have time to
show you guys that.
But if you click on that
one, it's really cool.
It shows you by proxy all
the errors, the codes,
and things like that.
Similar to the hot spots we
looked at in the monitoring
dashboard.
But anyway, here's some
reports that we have.
And I'm actually going to--
now, we have to be really
careful, because I'm
going to switch to
prod for a second,
because there's better data,
and you can see some cool stuff.
So one thing I will show
you, or tell you about,
is they group these things into
what they call report jobs.
So for example,
if I want to-- and
I'm going to kick one
off just to show you.
If I want to run
something that's
over a two-month period,
three-month period,
or whatever, it's not going
to sit there and wait.
They actually have
this new feature
that they launched where it
basically tells me, boom,
we're in the reports, we'll
let you know when it's done.
So that's pretty cool.
So while that's
running, I will show you
two reports that I ran
earlier, just to show you how
we use some of these reports.
So all right, so we
have this one here,
which is traffic for--
I'm going to show
two things here.
Bear with me.
All right, so I'll wait for
the other one to load up.
So what this is is this
is our traffic for Q2.
Let me-- kind of want to
get these side by side.
Hopefully this will work.
All right, so doing
the best I can, guys.
All right, so what
we have here is Q1.
And we have account data
service had 22 million calls.
That was all Q1.
Wow.
If we come over here to
Q2, the account service
had 140 million.
That is a massive spike.
And this is the
type of great stuff
that we get from a report,
because it's like, OK.
And look, as you see
here, I can drill down
into different apps
that are using these
and see that this CWC Control
Center V2 went from 20 million
to 122 million.
And I didn't have to do
anything on the backend.
I came right through
Apigee, and it's like, OK.
So I need to figure
out what's going on.
Why did these guys have
100 million more calls?
Are they expecting
this to be continued?
And these types of
things, this will drive
what we do for the quarter.
All right, if this
is going to be
the consistent
level of traffic, do
we need to increase our
servers on the backend?
Scale up in the cloud
and things like that.
Something else that we
noticed real quick--
I know I'm running
short on time.
But we noticed some other
groups had big increases,
and I reached out
to some of them.
And so what's happening
is they're like, oh yeah,
we have other teams within
our group that want to use it.
And so we shared our API key.
Well, that's a problem.
So you really should
not share your API key.
So an initiative
we're working on
is working with those groups,
tell us your other teams,
and we're breaking down their
API keys into more specific API
keys so we can more
accurately track the usage
of those specific teams.
So that's been
really key for us,
monitoring usage,
worrying about,
do we have the scale to
support increased usage
quarter over quarter,
and things like that.
Tracking who's using
keys, should they
be using those keys, and
things along those lines.
Like this one was a
big one, from Q1 to Q2,
because there's cost
impacts there as well.
So that's my time for
showing the demos.
Again, there's like
a ton more to show.
But I could kick
off seven reports.
And if they're taking too much
time or something like that,
I could come back and
it'll let me know.
And this one it won't
show because it's big.
So I can export
this, for example,
and view it in Excel
and other platforms.
And actually, I think Manoj is
going to talk about that a bit.
So--
MANOJ GUNTI: So thank
you so much, Adam.
ADAM BRANCATO:
--that's all I've got.
[INAUDIBLE] demos.
Back over to you, Manoj.
MANOJ GUNTI: Thank
you so much, Adam.
This is very insightful.
So before we go into
questions, I just
want to very quickly cover the
security reporting feature.
And before I talk
about this, I just
want to quickly
remind the audience,
if you have any
questions, please
don't wait until the
end of the webcast.
Please do post them
as soon as you have,
and we'll be able to answer
this in just about five minutes.
Last week, we announced a new
feature called API Security
Reporting.
And what this
feature essentially
addresses is for the
security operations people,
you can basically do
three different activities
on this feature.
One is you can very quickly
review which API proxies have
been configured
with which policies
across the entire organization.
And this is across environments.
This is across regions
and stuff like that.
So if you as a sec
ops person would
like to ensure that
all of your proxies
have been configured,
for example, let's say
[INAUDIBLE] policy, this is the
place where you can actually
quickly verify and cross-check.
And given the fact that
enterprises are now
exposing business critical and
sensitive information to APIs,
it is equally important
for the operations teams
to also ensure that the right
people have the right access
levels to the sensitive data.
So data protection
is another capability
within this feature,
where you can
see who within your
organization is
accessing the sensitive data.
Has there been any anomaly in
terms of their access patterns?
And if yes, then you can
quickly contact that person
and understand why he or
she is actually trying
to access the secure data.
You can also view who
within your organization
is exporting data out of the
platform to management APIs.
By the way, I forgot
to mention that all
of the capabilities
that you see in Apigee,
including the analytics,
the custom reporting,
including the
monitoring capabilities,
can all be done
outside of Apigee,
too, through the
management APIs.
And if you would like to be
part of this beta program,
and if you are already
an enterprise cloud
customer of Apigee, there is a
lot of documentation of this.
The feature is being
currently rolled out.
And if you're
already a customer,
you will see this
feature on your console,
probably by the
middle of next week.
And please use the documentation
to walk through this feature.
So all the capabilities
that we have seen until now
is what is out of box
available in Apigee Edge.
If this is all amazing stuff
you can do within Apigee Edge,
think of all the
different things
that you can do if you
could have the capability
to take this data out
of Apigee and combine it
with your proprietary
enterprise data,
and drive some business
and operational insights.
So Apigee also provides
the data export capability
where you can take big data
on a periodic basis every bit,
every byte of data,
into your DCP console.
And you can use it with
your CRM data, or ERP data,
or any other
proprietary information
to derive some benefits.
One of our customers,
Trustpilot,
is actually trying to
currently take the data out
of the system.
And they're trying to combine
it with their CRM data
to see what categories
of users are actually
using what API products,
for them to actually see
if there is an opportunity
to monetize these.
And if there is an
opportunity, what
are the different rate plans
and revenue models that they
can build out of it?
So we already worked on this.
If you're already an
Apigee identified customer,
so please go to the
documentation to get
started and
understand how you can
harness the power of API data.
And if you are not, please
go ahead and sign up
for a free trial of Apigee Edge.
With that, let's
take a few questions.
So Adam, this
question is for you.
The question is, do you
export any of the data
outside of the platform?
And if yes, how
are you using it?
ADAM BRANCATO: We do
export some of the data.
So there's a couple of ways.
A lot of these reports can
be exported out of Apigee
into things like Excel.
And then we actually, also, one
thing that wasn't really talked
about much, is a
lot of what you can
do in Apigee, like through
the UI, you can use--
or I'm sorry,
access through APIs.
So we actually pull
some of the Apigee data
through APIs into
our metrics reporting
to find out, like, we have
summaries we show about how
our apps are being used.
And we pull traffic
data, usage data
into some of our
quarterly stats monitoring
and presentations we
send to other people.
And then we also pull it
into some of our BI systems
so we can gauge how much
items are being used.
So one thing we've used some
of this traffic reporting for
is retiring old
services or APIs.
So we actually are moving
to a V2 of one of our APIs,
and it makes it
really easy to track
are people still using
it, who they are,
and contacting them to
encourage them to migrate.
MANOJ GUNTI: OK, perfect.
So we have one more question
on where these capabilities are
available.
Is it also available
on OPDK and hybrid?
So I think that's
a big question,
and I think I should take
some time to clarify this.
All the capabilities,
like the custom reporting,
the monitoring,
security reporting
that you see on Apigee platform
is available to our enterprise
cloud customers only.
And this will also be
very soon [INAUDIBLE]
into the hybrid model that
we are going [INAUDIBLE]
towards the end of this year.
But other than that,
OPDKs, these capabilities
are not available.
You can use your own proprietary
BI tools to extract this data
and actually build
some insights into it.
All right, I think we are almost
toward the end of the time.
This is all the questions
that we can take today.
If you have any more
questions, please
feel free to ping us
online, and we will be
more than happy to answer them.
That's all for today.
Have a nice rest of day.
ADAM BRANCATO: Cool.
Thanks, Manoj.
Thanks, everyone.
MANOJ GUNTI: Thank you, Adam.
[MUSIC PLAYING]